el año pasado ahi aqui asi bien las 24 horas
después de ese terremoto del 6 con el
último en la escala de Richter batidos vueltas
Lacosta va a salir de lo que tenga ahí
tercera estancia mas ia Esmirna y las
Islas griegas y avances y muertos
minuto a minuto seguir subiendo en las narices
momentos detrás de las distintas sillas aquí
sobre la ciencia y en esa misma É
continuando y con cada hora que pasa
no estas escuchando dar lugar a varios
personas pero tanto vivas como muertas
seguridad pública gobierno turco
atención en los minutos niño que ahora
nuestras personas frontales esperan que Deva
ser duro destruido que son las ventas
según el gobierno no fue allá a ver donde
son los más perjudicados
otros esperan que te duren
troll y probablemente camino y pasado
si funciona o no podemos Smith
Herrero murió
los militares o en palabras hechas con
esa roca adolescente por debajo de 50 mil
Simpsons Villas of the Turks vive en un
país que está corto situado en la parte superior de la
sobre la falla tectónica muy activa y pronto
terremotos entraron creación de constantes
anual olvidar muchos de los cuales de
Víctimas mortales como se vería